but I think a lot of times like what I
was getting at is like men will always
run the infrastructure of society like
if our jobs go away tomorrow tomorrow
Society will still run we're mad at some
women's jobs yeah of course yeah yeah
but if women stop having babies Society
is also over yeah but if men stop
getting women pregnant it's like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but there's no
there's no reason to say one is less
than the other there's just clear facts
right you understand what I'm saying but
they're like controversial now but it
shouldn't be it's very it's very cut and
dry as clear as [__] day
it is well okay to the average person
we're in a penthouse right now right
yeah multiple cranes throughout London I
can guarantee you there's not one woman
not only not in the crane but on the
ground doing the work there's not one I
agree it's just a matter of fact thing